ones that have had a very busy weekend
dropping all kinds of announcements and
trailers for their various franchises at
Blizzcon but what about a new Warcraft
strategy game Starcraft 2 lead developer
to Morton told GameSpot that Starcraft 3
or Warcraft 4 could be developed and
that it all depends on what the fans say
they want he explains what the future
holds really depends so much on what we
hear back from players we love RTS we
love this genre the Starcraft universe
is fantastic the Warcraft universe
clearly has more stories that can be
told there are new Blizzard I pave
there's the potential to make completely
new stories all together we want to hear
back from our players what they would be
excited about
he added that the developer have simply
been too busy at work on legacy of the
void to make any decisions as to where
they will go next in terms of
development it was announced at Blizzcon
that the next installment in the
Starcraft universe after legacy of the
void will be a series of episodic
adventures to out next year Morton said
they opted for episodic content instead
of a full sequel or a new trilogy
because they wanted to be able to
continue delivering new campaign-style
content to fans the game will have three
acts with three missions each Moulton
added at the end of that we'll be
interested to see how player response is
and if players feel like we should build
more content like that or are they
looking for a new full game what is that
they want to see out of StarCraft and
out of RTS let me know what you think
down in the comments and be sure to let
me know if you became to play Starcraft
3 or Warcraft 4 stay tuned again [ __ ]
for all the latest